hello everybody and welcome to episode
nine of my flipping series um first off
we're going to start by doing the wheel
spin uh from last episode 1.1 mil is
going to go to one of these people cuz
they commented in the last video the
winner is Tom Darnell congratulations
you won 1.1 mil I will send you a
message that we can organize um for you
to get it all right let's jump into the
video
here Tom Darnell where are you at did
you leave your
name
uh so these cabbages are taking four
forever to buy so we are pulling the
offer out we only bought one at the low
price so we're going to put the high
offer in for you Tom uh because it's
going to take way too long uh so yeah
give me a second here I will probably
get you about 25k cabbages I will bump
it up there just because I could not get
it for low price for you unfortunately
as you can probably tell in the
background I've actually changed to
resizable mode uh going forward
recording the clips I've received a
couple comments regarding this and I
agree with them it is much easier to see
the flipping interface well not really
flipping interface the grand exchange
interface so in the future when I'm
recording flipping videos I will be
using resizable mode let me know in the
the comments down below if you like the
change it's is just a little test run
it'll still probably be a week before
all my Clips are recorded like this but
yeah let me
know hey hello everybody and welcome to
episode 9 of my buying and selling and
pay play series where we're going to go
from Z to 100 Mil using the grand
exchange only um this episode we're
starting about 9.8 mil so we're very
close to the green cash stack now
because I was gone for almost 8 Days um
I don't think we're going to make much
progress in the overall goal of getting
to 100 Mil um but we hopefully should at
least break even and um yeah we got a
couple new items this episode so let's
just jump right into it here and first
up I think we're going to do the super
defense potion had about a 250 GP margin
on each potion uh hopefully n us about 4
500k which would be pretty decent so if
I buy these super energy potions for the
low price I actually would get 400 GP
margin on them which is insane that's
like 800k if we actually buy and sell
all of them um I don't think I can
afford the full amount but we'll get
1,700 and we'll get them for the low
price and we'll just hope for the
best so everything I've sold and once
again we've done really good on these
super defense potions um we actually
sold them in two different clumps but we
ended up making a Bo 430k from the super
defenses which is pretty good and um the
energy potions we got 183 GP on each one
um we didn't get that many of them we
only got like 500 but that still gave us
92k well we haven't done this item in
quite a while but uh the party hat set
actually has a 7K Marg on it which is
really good especially for how expensive
it is so we're going to buy 100 of these
and yeah we should buy 100 we should get
700k which be awesome uh next up we're
going to do the Redwood logs they had
about a 85 GP margin on them and while
they are still dropping they've been
doing so pretty much since they've been
released um it's such a big margin that
I think we should be safe buying them
still so we made actually a decent
little bit of profit on these two items
uh the Redwood logs they did both of
them did crash but um like I was saying
they didn't crash enough cuz there was
such a big margin on them um the Redwood
logs we ended up only getting a 33 GP
margin on but um we still got pretty
much all of them for 5,500 given us
about 181k which is awesome um the party
hats we still almost got a 5k margin on
each one did crash a bit but not a whole
lot and we got 29 of the hats so that's
142k so pretty decent uh we might try
these again sometime actually and lastly
here we're going to do the barrows
teleport not really sure if this is a
good idea but it does have a 200 GP
margin on it uh which pretty decent they
are very inflated right now so they
could crash back down so this isn't an
great idea by any means but um we'll do
anyway so we'll check back when some of
the stuff is
sold so unfortunately guys the Redwood
logs have crashed a little bit uh so we
actually ended up losing about a 131k on
them which kind of sucks but uh that
does happen sometimes um so whatever but
um the teleports we got about 50k on so
we actually end up losing only about 70k
um for the amount of times it actually
happens so I'm pretty lucky but you can
see right there yeah we lost well we
lost a good amount of money but it
definitely could have been worse so
let's go and try to get the money back
so first up we're going to do the Ring
of dueling actually um actually only has
a 60 GP margin on it you can see right
there but um since these are traded so
frequently this may actually be worth it
so we'll give us a try we're going to
pull up it in for $24.98 and we'll get I
think a couple thousand of these maybe
3,000 so the super defense potion
actually looks pretty good again so
we'll go ahead and buy a couple thousand
of these as well um this item has been
consistently really good so I'd
recommend it if you want to make some
easy money uh yes we'll check back when
these have sold so the Rings have sold
we didn't make very much on them only
like 22k maybe or something like that um
we actually tried to buy a guilded spear
with the rest of our money uh that
didn't buy unfortunately either and the
super defense potions we did not buy any
I guess the price must have been wrong
or changed quickly so we're just going
to have to redo a couple things here so
we're going to do the rings of dueling
again even though they didn't work that
well um we didn't lose money on them so
we'll go ahead I think we're going to
buy 3,000 of the Rings and hope they
they work better this time the 22k was a
bit lame and lastly here we're going to
put an offer in for just one Infinity
hat as well uh we have been making about
100K on each one in the past so we'll
see how this works
out we are back um so we've sold the
rings of dueling but we only got 27 of
them that being said we got like 800 GP
on each one which is pretty insane um
given us only like 23k but still if we
had bought more we would have gotten a
bunch of money from that we also put an
offer in for some super strength potions
which we got 100 GP on each and we got
about 1,800 of those so that's about 185
190k from that it's not too bad but um
we really are trying to get some items
going that aren't potions that work well
and these dueling Rings could have
worked but we just did not buy enough of
them so let's try one more
time so we are going to try the magic
Fang but unfortunately I messed this up
again I put in the wrong Buy price I do
is way too much so we're going to buy
three and then one instantly buy so
quickly take it out I can see there have
one instantly bought so obviously we
don't have the right price so basically
we probably going to lose money on that
magic Fang um but we'll have to go and
check the margin again and we'll be
right back and buy a couple more so we
are back and yeah we were quite off
actually we thought they were
3548 um but you can see actually
3458 um so we're about 100K off
unfortunately so um we'll probably still
make some money is assuming we do get
100K on each of these so yeah we'll come
back when that these two have
bought so we are back and we've actually
sold them all for 3.
515k and they all sold pretty
quickly um we lost money on one of them
and we gained money on two of them so in
the end we ended up making a 3K on the
flip which is pretty good for actually
goofing that up again so we started this
episode at 9.8 mil and we are pretty
much at 10.9 mil now so we made about
172k uh which is pretty good but I was
kind of hoping to make a little bit more
but hopefully next episode we can kind
of get ourselves more ahead cuz right
now we are in the green cash de but um
like I was saying I was gone for quite a
while so we might break even on this
week but hopefully going forward I can
start seeing some bigger progress so
thanks for watching guys and I will see
you guys in episode
[Music]